- So Exactly what is Drew's News?
We like to say it's the
news served sunny side up.
So let's see what made the papers.
Okay, first up, this
summer, I was really honored
to be on the cover of InStyle Magazine.
And my old friend, Laura Brown,
who's the editor-in-chief
allowed me to wear
one of my personal vintage
T-shirts on the cover.
Fun fact, magazines make money
by featuring designers on their covers.
And it's a form of advertising
and revenue for them.
But we got to break the rules
by wearing this Detroit News T-shirt.
After that, the Detroit News
saw this and reissued them,
'cause they weren't making these anymore,
as a part of a fundraising effort
for Detroit area college scholarships.
Well, yesterday the Detroit
News itself reported
that sales of the shirt
have raised over $70,000!
(audience cheers)
I mean, things are possible.
That's what the evidence of this is.
So if you'd like to contribute,
head over to our website for a link.
And all the proceeds go directly
to the Rosa L. Parks
Scholarship Foundation.
So let's do this, let's raise
more money, do some good.
This is evidence, it's happening.
(audience cheers)
Okay, now seriously, I don't like to get
into controversial items on Drew's News,
but I'm gonna have to tackle
this next issue head on.
It's a debate that's gone
viral this week on Twitter,
and it continues to heat
up more and more each day.
And the question is, if a giraffe
were to wear a bow tie,
where would the bow tie go?
I'm vacillating.
I think we can all agree it
just looks better up top,
a pop up color to accentuate the eyes.
But if you think about
it, humans wear a bow tie
at the bottom of their
neck as part of the outfit.
Okay, we have some opposing views
with our virtual friends, David and Alex.
You have varying opinions,
let's hear them out loud.
David, you go first.
(audience cheers)
- Well Drew, I gotta say,
I think the bow tie goes
up closer to the top.
Just makes more sense there.
- [Drew] Yeah, I hear you.
Alex, rebuttal.
- Hi Drew, sorry, I'm just
really excited to talk to you.
- Oh, I'm excited to talk to you too.
- But I actually feel
very confident answering this question.
I am a designer in the fashion industry.
So-
- An authority.
- (laughs) I personally have never
seen anybody wear a bow
tie under their chin,
I don't know about David.
But I personally believe that it needs
to be down by the shoulders,
if it is worn properly.
- I hear you both, it's a tough call,
but I'm gonna go with my
gut on this one, either way.
Giraffes should wear bow
ties, wherever they want.
They're stylish and plain old fun.
Okay, you do you, giraffes.
And thanks, Alex and
David, you're the best.
All right, debate settled.
Finally, it's no secret
we love good news here.
And this story is a perfect example
of the good we need in the world.
Tyler and Melanie are
newlyweds from Parma, Ohio.
And they had to cancel their wedding
because of everything that's happening.
And rather than get a
refund for all the catering,
they decided to donate the
food to a local shelter.
And it is so wonderful, we
just had to talk to them.
So hello, Tyler and Melanie.
(audience cheers)
Thank you for coming on the show!
- Well, we're excited to
be here, this is crazy.
- I just wanna say, we kinda match.
- Oh, by the way, totally do.
In fact, we're kind of wearing bows,
if you get what I'm saying, everyone.
- They're lower, though.
- I didn't even realize this.
Okay, this is all so
serendipitous, all right.
Well, and before we get into
the amazing thing that you did,
I just have to know how you guys met.
- So we actually met at
our friend's wedding.
We were partnered up.
I kinda feel like they
did that on purpose.
But we actually had a moment during it.
We were taking pictures,
and I fell into him,
and we kind of both just stood there.
And I think at that moment
we both kinda were like,
oh, we kind of have this spark.
So we went with it, and here we are.
- Do you know?
Oh sorry, go ahead.
- No, no, no, I was just gonna
say it was a magical moment.
It truly was.
- Do you know how many
people like get dressed up
and go to a wedding with
so much hope, you know?
I mean, you guys are kind of proving
that things are really possible
and to keep hope alive.
Okay, so rather than
canceling the catering,
you donated this to a local shelter.
Why did you do this?
- Oh, I mean we were working
with the caterer for quite some time.
And we've gotten to be
pretty good friends with them, actually.
And when COVID hit, all
the local businesses
started to really take a hit.
And we felt terrible that
they were going to lose out.
So every year we donate somewhere,
typically around Christmas, to children,
to get different gifts for
them for underprivileged.
So the way things lined
up, it just seemed right
for us to donate the food
and help somebody out.
- I think you guys are just so amazing.
And I heard a rumor that
you bought a new house?
- We did, we've been here
for like three months now.
It's a little bit of a fixer upper.
We had to paint this whole room.
It was wonderful.
But yeah, we're really excited.
Our neighbors are amazing.
They have babies, so we
get to play with them.
It's so much fun, so.
- Well, this is perfect,
because I wanted to
give you a wedding gift.
We are gonna give you a...
I love design so much.
I have a furniture company
called Flower Home.
And today we wanna gift you a
$5,000 credit for Flower Home.
So you can get anything you want
as you begin your life together.
And if you want, Anna and Francesca,
who are the creative directors,
and I design everything with,
they're the coolest women,
we are all gonna personally help you
put it together to make
your space perfect.
So thank you for being here
and sharing your story.
- I don't cry normally, so here I am.
- Thanks you guys so much.
Tyra Banks is next.
We'll be right back, thank you.
We wanna make your dream home.
(upbeat music)